on cold dark winter nights you might
catch a glimpse of a horned figure
stalking through the streets with the
basket strapped to its back and a switch
in hand the demonic krampus isn't
interested in giving out gifts but
doling out brutal punishments
krampus is the dark foil to saint
nicholas the miraculous catholic bishop
credited with bringing small gifts of
sweets nuts and fruit to good little
boys and girls in early december and yes
one of the inspirations behind jolly old
you know who
but what are the origins of the demonic
horned creature you might be surprised
to learn this winter monster isn't as
old as you might have been led to
believe
and even more importantly why invent a
yuletide character that literally beats
children into submission
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
the krampus historical origins are
generally believed to have emerged onto
the yuletide scene in slavic and
austrian celebrations
winter festivals in the alpine regions
of austria hungary slovenia croatia
germany and italy all feature versions
of this monstrous anti-santa though
originally krampus was really more of a
category of monster rather than the name
of an individual creature
the word itself comes from either the
middle german fur claw or the bavarian
word for something lifeless and dried
out with plenty of regional variations
half goat half demon krampus are fanged
with cloven feet and often long pointed
tongues the oldest and most traditional
versions have multiple sets of horns
they may carry a pitchfork and a basket
to collect children in and they always
have that switch in their hand most
often one made of birch branches the
better to beat you with my dear yep
that's what this charming monster does
doles out corporal punishment to
children who misbehave
krompus emerged in alpine folklore
alongside celebrations of saint nicholas
at first it was more of an idea an
amorphous threatening boogeyman parents
evoked to keep kids in line when food
was scarce and attention wavered during
the long dark nights of winter in the
mountains
nice children received presents from
saint nick naughty children received a
birch branch spanking from krampus or
worse the most wickedly behaved were
shackled and tossed into the monster's
wooden basket to be carried away to the
fires of hell
or you know eaten by the krampus
the traditions connecting krampus and
saint nicholas seem interwoven through
time despite some conflicting versions
of how they came to be associated there
is evidence of performances that link
the krampus to satan in jesuit theater
and the monster frequently appears in
saint nicholas plays so it is possible
that the beast was constructed to
represent the opposite of divinity
detailed descriptions of krampus only
emerge in the 19th century when
folklorists began recording the costumes
worn during krampuslauf or krompus run
in the alpine region december 5th marks
a celebratory and usually drunken parade
in which people dressed as krompus walk
through the streets scaring bystanders
and chasing down the really unlucky ones
even if people dressed as krampus don't
actually injure people they are a
symbolic threat of violence and
rebellion against decorum
in some regions krampus troops stock the
streets from november to christmas
these troops consist of multiple
revelers and it's considered an honor
and often a rite of passage to don the
horns in the oldest traditions of the
alpine region krampus revelers would
either blacken their faces don a dark
false beard and dress in dark clothing
or they wore wooden masks and long fur
coats sporting belts with large bells
and that switch in their hand of course
in catholic areas where fear of the
devil was stronger the costume included
horns to highlight their evil nature
krampus masks are often called larvin
from the latin word larva that means
both mask and ghost
traditional masks are grotesque with
exaggerated features and gaping mouths
accented by massive animal horns usually
multiple pairs from different animals
the woodcarvers who craft these masks
are considered well-respected masters
also in the mid-19th century the monster
became associated with santa claus the
more secular version of saint nicholas
around this time is also where we see
the moniker krompus enter
in 1862 a newspaper in budapest was
published under krampus name and in 1865
it published an image of santa claus
with krompus lurking behind him
solidifying the creature's appearance
and transferring the connection to the
christian holiday of christmas
rather than the holy saints feast day
claims that krampus is derived from
pagan traditions intending to drive away
winter and evil spirits and an ancient
fertility rite are unfounded in reality
there is no evidence for this scholars
found that the false pagan origin story
of krampus was invented in the early
20th century by socialist folklorists
attempting to cast christianity as a
practice that sullied ancient nordic
customs the nazi party reinforced this
false claim publishing a photo essay
portraying the krampus as an ancient
custom quote banned for its pagan roots
in reality krampus knights weren't
recorded until 1582 in the bavarian town
of diesen in passing reference under the
name perk the perkton are mischievous
alpine spirits and the likely folkloric
precursors to the krampus documents from
the 17th and 18th centuries show
salzburg archbishops trying to ban the
krampus tradition
with little success
interestingly these bans were not about
the monster itself but were aimed at
curbing the raucous celebrations that
accompanied them in the 19th century the
krampus lao tradition dwindled preserved
only in a small number of austrian and
german towns until the 1870s as
consumerism boomed more specifically red
postcards with illustrations of the
monster appeared in austria-hungary in
the later half of the century austria's
postal system became the first to
deliver postcards in 1867 making the
sending of krampus cards in the late
1880s possible and financially viable
the cards became incredibly popular a
nostalgic reminder for austrians and
germans who moved from rural areas where
krampus runs were popular to
industrialize cities
unsurprisingly these postcards often
show the horned monster punishing
children
or in a seemingly bizarre twist
accompanied by semi-naked women perhaps
because of these associations with both
youth and sexuality in some parts of
austria children are told that being hit
with krampus switch brings fertility
while globally krampus popularity
suffered from the early 20th century
associations with socialism and the nazi
party in the latter part of the century
the demonic figure has made a comeback
since the turn of the 21st century
krampus events have become larger and
more numerous across the globe
whether this is due to a renewed
interest in preserving traditional
regional customs as globalization
emerges or a rebellious response to the
over commodification and
commercialization of christmas the death
metal version of santa is making a play
to take back the winter holidays
the internet's discovery of the 19th
century krampus cards brought renewed
interest to the monster
in 2012 an episode of the scooby-doo
mystery incorporated cartoon focused on
krampus and that same year gerald
braum's book krampus the yule lord
further increased the popularity of the
monster
and connected him to a false backstory
in nordic mythology and made him an
enemy of santa claus movies books and
other popular cultured texts in america
have perpetuated the connection between
santa and krampus
horror films featuring the krampus
emerged around 2010 and the monster has
been a staple ever since
the 2015 film krampus plays on the santa
claus krampus connection explicitly with
krampus coming down chimneys wearing a
red fur trimmed coat and slaughtering
people commercialism morbid fascination
reclamation whatever draws people to
krampus allows tradition to be shared
and preserved
in 2014 unesco even declared the krampus
play of the town of oblarn and styria as
vital to the cultural heritage of
humanity which proves to me that it's
not only the good guys that get
immortalized the monsters get their
place in history too
so this winter holiday season don't
forget to play nice boys and girls or
you might get a visit from this yuletide
monster
before you go we wanted to invite you to
participate in pbs digital studios
annual audience survey your feedback
really helps us understand what our
audience is interested in so we can give
you more of it you even get to vote on
potential new shows there's a link in
the description below if you have a few
minutes we'd love your input thanks
half goat half demon
what a combo wearing a red fur trimmed
coat and slaughtering people
i was way too excited about the
slaughtering people
you